peter coughlin has been fishing off the
coast of hastings for nearly half a
century
he doesn't mind if britain leaves
without a deal far from it
it will feel as though we're going back
40 years
when they wouldn't in our waters when we
could go and fish
and catch fish or she'll even have a
drink and i haven't had a drink for the
last
five or six years i've been a tea total
but uh
i will definitely get the ramen i think
brexit negotiations have gone cold
and the will to find a solution seems to
be fraying at the edges
we want to know deal basically you know
for for us we just want our waters back
so for a no deal for us
that's just what anyone wants i don't
think there's a fisherman alive that
doesn't
want no deal i can't see that
because we're not going to deal with
europe but
we ain't all going to die are we the
royal navy is now on standby to protect
british waters
with four patrol vessels poised to
deploy
it could be a move designed to avoid
scenes like these
when english and french fishing fleets
clashed off the coast of normandy in
2018
that was a row over whether the british
should be allowed to land
scallops here we are these undignified
uh
reports suggesting that where our
overstretched
royal navies is going to square up to a
nato ally
over fishing vessel rights in brussels
negotiations have all but
broken down an impasse on a level
playing field for trade and fishing
seemingly impossible to overcome it all
comes down to whether boris
johnson and ursula van der leyen the
president of the european commission
can somehow pull off a christmas miracle
and so on sunday both sides will get
together to decide
whether there is any point in continuing
these negotiations
nobody wants to give an inch at this
stage
and even if all of this is just
theatrics
the gulf between the two is so great
it's hard to see
where a deal would come from
the contingency planning is well
underway now not just on the sea but on
the land
no deal in the new year looking likely
nick martin sky news